we had a couple calls that came in and
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna pepper
those in with my own thoughts and ideas
let's start off with one of those here
we go
hey Theo it's Chris calling from wall
domain wall domain and we I'm sure
everybody pull of Where's Waldo on it
and I dressed up like Where's Waldo one
time for Halloween more than one time
before everybody else did and everybody
got onto that [ __ ] for a while I did
that [ __ ] when I was in eighth grade and
my boy tically Todd drank some gasoline
at the gas station we're also on
mushrooms and he had to go home early
onward thanks for calling Chris I'm just
calling about your topic of the state's
going against each other in like a war
scenario and basically my idea is Maine
my home state would be most likely to be
successful in this situation because
from all the wholehearted people here
you know we okay you say amazingly
successful because of the wholehearted
people this isn't a bake-off Chris okay
this isn't recipes aren't coming into
play this is a war brother this isn't
who gots the most pecans and their you
know in their basket wholeheartedness
ain't gonna help this isn't who owns the
most episodes of Little House on the
Prairie on cassette let's hear more
we have dairy farmers we have lobster
men we have everybody out here so bright
y'all got milk and shellfish two of the
most um things that people are most
allergic to dairy and shellfish y'all
gonna have gout and diarrhea bruh by the
end of the first battle let's hear more
oh it's I once knew a lobster man he was
fishing out there and he was bait in the
trap because there's bait bags I go in
the lobster traps and he broke his
finger on that fishing boat he drank
himself gallon I think it was or a half
gallon of coffee brandy and he was good
to go it's their medicine out here so
it's you give our war force a little bit
of
Coffee brandy some half-and-half milk
from our strong dairy farmers I think
honestly we would succeed succeed it
would succeed is seasickness you just
you just name one man who broke his
finger trying to fish so I gotta say out
of the gate main would be out I've been
up to mean it's a lot of people growing
their own weed arguing with the cops and
the cops are also at home growing their
own weed okay I spent some time off
Islesboro island out there john travolta
country went and we had dinner with
Kirstie Alley one time when I was a
child a friend of mine knew her and I
tried to finger bang a chicken and attic
out there who I was in love with who out
first and also hit a bat with a um hit
up like a vampire not a vampire bat but
like a regular American bat with a
tennis racket so I've been through some
[ __ ] out there you know Maine is just a
bunch of unfinished houses a lot of rain
water I mean it's good people you got
the black bears that shells state bass
cot for this for the for the state for
the for the college University of Maine
I think but I'm gonna say this I don't
think you guys get out of that bracket
out of that northeastern bracket no way
uh you guys are probably the y'all would
escape to Canada out of the gate I'm
gonna say that from Maine you know New
Hampshire's right there with you guys I
think new you know I mean New Hampshire
I think most y'all's force would
probably be I'm guessing wholehearted
lesbians you know you want to talk about
wholehearted I'm talking about that
vitamin D a hundred percent milk fat
lesbians that would be a lot of that
workforce that war force out of New
Hampshire and I think that HAMP right
there would I think that HAMP I mean
here's the thing that Maine does have
though man has a lot of people that are
used to living in the woods so you'd
have that kind of malicious style but
y'all are a lot of vegans dude a lot of
people up there eating raspberries and
you know you know cultivated scabs you
know just bad granola it's a lot I don't
think y'all gonna have the energy to
withstand y'all know about a lot of
roots and stuff I guess you could live
in the woods for a while so I'd say this
Maine would beat New Hampshire I think
you guys would probably struggle
against Vermont and Vermont and New
Hampshire let's be honest they're really
just the same thing to people okay I
know that uh you know New Hampshire I
think is John Irving country he wrote a
lot of those books Cider House Rules
you know you got a lot of wrestlers and
a lot of rich lot of rich kids up there
going to private schools and stuff like
that but the truth is that's a great
white north a lot of people hopped up on
syrup sucking on trees smoking dope you
know you got the basketball team up
there the Catamounts I don't think
that's gonna hell you know yeah they're
super pale way pale you know people look
like they're allergic to the Sun I don't
think anybody makes it out of that
bracket evening good afternoon and other
times thanks for watching that video you
just saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one